never-ending drama for Johnny Depp yeah  not only with X Amber Heard but now  Rihanna yeah E.T confirmed Johnny's  upcoming appearance at Riri Savage X  Fenty fashion show and that is sparking  major backlash today  hey you know what  I needed the work  with quotes like delete the Johnny Depp  scene now or we will boycott the show  and really disappointing Rihanna Twitter  lit up with outrage over the actor's  upcoming Cameo we're told Depp has  already filmed his part for the show  dropping Wednesday on Prime video the  choice is controversial especially  considering Rihanna was assaulted by  Chris Brown back in 2009 and Johnny was  accused but denies abusing Amber Heard  oh and those two keep going at it Johnny  just filed to appeal his ex's two  million dollar defamation trial win as  for Amber well she has seemingly  deactivated her Twitter account just as  her other ex Elon Musk bought the  company for 44 billion